[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance the incoming cabinet and
White House staff of the idiot elect is
so collectively and individually
nefarious so reeking of financial
corruption and moral decay that it
beggars political comparison teapot dome
boss tweed and the bush-cheney
Halliburton redistribution of wealth and
the financial scandals of the presidency
of ulysses s grant are insufficient we
literally have to compare this again to
use John Cleese's line this crew of a
governmental pirate ship to Batman
villains all Batman villains all of them
in one movie like the Adam West movie
with the Joker the penguin the Riddler
Catwoman and the other denizens of what
the filmmakers dubbed United underworld
let's meet them and let's dub them
Citizens United underworld starting in
the cabinet and this first one may be
the least offensive the nominee for
Secretary of Defense James mattis who
noted once that it's fun to shoot some
people and Hooper federal law is not
actually eligible to become Secretary of
Defense until May 22nd 2020 because a
Secretary of Defense must be retired
seven years from active military service
Trump's gonna get them to wave that wave
this madness is on the board of General
Dynamics which makes tanks and
submarines and other stuff the Pentagon
boys like to buy and he may be the best
of them Betsy DeVos Secretary of
Education nominee big advocate of
spending public money on religious
schools than 15 years ago she told a
conference of Christians that doing that
was an opportunity to quote advance
God's kingdom Secretary of Education
under a president-elect who said we
should be teaching patriotism in the
schools there would be Secretary of
Health and Human Services congressman
and orthopedic surgeon Tom price he is
reported to be a member of the
Association of American physicians and
surgeons which opposes vaccination
programs in schools which suggested a
link between abortion and breast cancer
and which once posted an article on its
website that postulated presidential
candidate Barack Obama was so popular
because in his speeches he was using a
hidden form of hypnosis a Secretary of
Health and Human
services who is a member of an
organization full of vaccines and who
believes in hypnotoad the Attorney
General you know Jeff Sessions the
senator representing the Keebler Elf
Magic Tree prosecuted black voters in
Alabama for voting allegedly called the
ACLU and n-double-a-cp unamerican
admitted during testimony to the Senate
that he believed the n-double-a-cp and
one other group quote may have taken
positions that I consider to be averse
to the security interests of the United
States the other group was the National
Council of Churches Transportation
Secretary nominee Elaine Chao from the
Bush administration where she was the
labor secretary where she drastically
cut the roster of mine safety inspectors
and the number of mine inspections just
before 18 miners and three rescue
workers were killed it's a go in West
Virginia and Crandall Canyon and Utah
plus she's married to senator Mitch
McConnell which suggests she has no
judgment whatsoever Wilbur Ross commerce
the supposed wizard of the distressed
assets business except that his
distressed assets business fund tanked
every bet on dry bulk shipping and on
Greek banks Greek banks even I know not
to invest in Greek banks Trump's Man for
Treasury Steve manuka mm-hmm seven years
ago he and his cronies brought a failed
mortgage company IndyMac they foreclosed
on as many as 36,000 homeowners
including one woman aged 90 after a
payment error she reportedly owed 27
cents so mr. mm-hmm company threw her
out over the case of 27 cents here are a
few Batman villains mentioned but not
yet named for other cabinet posts at the
Department of Agriculture Sid Miller
called Hillary Clinton the c-word also
has a Facebook page filled with fake
news including details of the secret
Houston jihad training camp that doesn't
exist possible Secretary of the Interior
former Arizona Governor Jan Brewer who
once insisted the desert covering her
States border with Mexico
was full of severed heads rumored at the
Veterans Administration Scott Brown
former Massachusetts senator also former
nude model prospective head of the
Office of Management and Budget Gary
cone president of Goldman Sachs Goldman
Sachs the company Trump alleged Hillary
Clinton was in the pocket of Goldman
Sachs which Trump supporters chanted at
Ted Cruz Goldman Sachs which reportedly
concludes that current Republican tax
plans will increase the debt to one
trillion dollars by 2020 but that
Trump's tax plan will increase it to one
and a half trillion at Homeland Security
Milwaukee County Sheriff David Clarke
who has had four deaths in his jail
since April and when a County Supervisor
criticized him over that he called for
the county supervisor to be prosecuted
Clark also insisted the presidential
election was rigged and thus quote in
his pitchfork and torch his time in
America after Trump won that election
that Clark insists was rigged Clark
didn't understand why anybody was
protesting quote these temper tantrums
from these radical anarchists must be
quelled he said there is no legitimate
reason to protest the will of the people
yeah and a sanity test I'm not betting
on him to pass then there's X campaign
manager Kellyanne Conway who could wind
up somewhere she got into a shouting
match last week with Clinton campaign
people when their manager accused Conway
of providing quote a platform for white
supremacists Conway feigned shock said
hashtag he's your president and later
whined that she took the comment
personally she should take it personally
if you abetted Trump you are either a
white supremacist or somebody who does
not mind white supremacist Kellyanne
Conway which is worse named two non
cabinet positions senior counselor chief
strategist Steven Bannon from Breitbart
a website that makes [ __ ] up last week
as the idiot elect walked near and then
amid a group of photographers and
reporters Bannon asked a press aide
quote who are all these photographers
and why are they here there came the
answer quote this is the press pool
chief of strategic you say deputy
national security adviser katie
mcfarland who six
years ago called a secret sleeker a
quote terrorist that was Julian Assange
that was before Julian Assange started
working to get Trump elected McFarland's
website Twitter account and Facebook
page were all scrubbed off the internet
this week one overview this tweet from
somebody named Proust Melman mocking the
Bernie Sanders tweet about the Trump
administration of by and for the
millionaires and billionaires
interesting to see Democrats selected
populism he writes rich Obama nominees
get confirmed rich Trump nominees get
attacked the net worth of the nine Obama
people they're a combined four hundred
and ninety seven million six hundred
thousand dollars which is a lot less a
lot less the combined worth of the nine
rich Obama appointees is one-fifth of
what Wilbur Ross is worth by himself
it is one-tenth of what Betsy DeVos and
her family are worth alone oh and one
guy I have left out former Lieutenant
General and now National Security
Advisor Michael Flynn who thinks CNN and
MSNBC are state-run television who has
taken payments from the Russians and it
was one of those jackasses tweeting the
rumors linking Hillary Clinton to
pedophilia his own son helped spread the
specific false internet story that
Clinton was involved in some kind of
child sex ring centered in a Washington
pizza restaurant a restaurant into which
walk last Sunday a man carrying a rifle
who said he was there to self
investigate the story National Security
Advisor Michael Flynn he could have
gotten innocent Americans killed with
his computer Trump wants him there to
tell him when to start blowing things up
seven hours after that incident Flynn's
son tweeted that paranoid fantasy that
sent all this off had not yet been
proven to be false and thus would remain
a story and Flynn's son by the way is
not just some random idiot he has an
official dot-gov email as part of the
Trump transition team general Flynn and
his idiot son have no business in any
government except perhaps that
of North Korea but therein lies the
problem with the Batman villains of the
Trump administration they are so
over-the-top
you think they cannot be real and then
along comes Donald Trump and for the
record Trump is not the puzzler from
Batman that was the actor Maurice Evans
any similarity is purely coincidental
resist peace